otra vacuna en el arsenal de eeuu el
fármaco de moderna recibió la
autorización de la fda para empezar a
distribuir sus dosis esta ley esta
autorización de la vacuna contra el cob
y 19 de modernas llega una semana
después de que autorizara mos la de
facer y vayan tec con la autorización de
la afe de esta vacuna adicional pronto
será distribuida a través del país por
nuestros socios federales
el presidente de donald trump celebró la
aprobación en su cuenta de 'twitter' la
autorización se produce con la cifra más
alta de muertes en el mundo por el virus
como telón de fondo el número diario ha
superado los 2.500 fallecimientos en los
últimos días oficiales estadounidenses
están tratando de promover la
inmunización con el vicepresidente de
mike pence su esposa karen y el
principal funcionario sanitario que
recibieron las dosis de la vacuna de
facer y bayonne tec en un evento
televisado las autoridades esperan que
con dos vacunas autorizadas el país
pueda estar cerca de acabar con la
pandemia
entre países y moderna deberíamos tener
suficientes dosis este mes de diciembre
para inmunizar a los primeros 20
millones de ciudadanos en lo que
esperamos que sea un gran impulso para
dejar el virus detrás aunque tomará
muchos meses más llegar a todos los
estadounidenses
se ha probado que la vacuna de moderna
es efectiva en un 95% cerca de seis
millones de dosis están listas para ser
despachadas desde este fin de semana
contrario a la vacuna de facer y bayón
tech el fármaco de moderna no tiene que
ser almacenado en congeladores
especiales o con hielo seco lo que hace
más sencilla su distribución las
autoridades esperan que la vacuna sea
entregada primero en hospitales de áreas
rurales